-Our next guest
is an Emmy-nominated actor
you know from his work
in "Full Metal Jacket"
and as the mysterious
Dr. Brenner
on "Stranger Things."
The highly anticipated
volume 2 of season 4
is available to stream
on Netflix starting July 1st.
Let's take a look.
-All I've ever wanted to do
is to help you.
And right now, I think
you very much need my help.
Your gifts have been stolen.
I believe I know why.
And I believe
I know how to get them back.
Let us work together again,
you and I.
Daughter...and Papa.
-Please welcome to the show
Matthew Modine, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome!
I'm so happy you're here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm so happy to be here.
-So we're neighbors in New York,
I have heard.
I've never seen you
around the neighborhood,
but you have seen me.
-I have seen you, yeah.
I've often wanted
to come up and say hello,
but you're busy talking.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I found out today
that you have three children.
-Yeah.
-And so I realize it might be
the only time
you get an opportunity to talk
is to yourself,
out on the streets of New York.
-Yeah.
I mostly wanted you
to say that on TV
'cause it'll make my wife so
happy, because she always says,
"You have to stop
talking to yourself.
People are gonna think
you're an insane person."
So you were --
I remember this episode,
but you were here in this
building in 1988 hosting "SNL."
You have -- I want to say,
you have great hair now.
Makes sense, 'cause you had
great hair then.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that.
And a suit jacket
for a much larger man.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
What was that?
The big shoulder pads.
-I know.
It's really --
Yeah, I feel very lucky to have
not been famous in 1988.
[ Laughter ]
Did you enjoy that experience
of doing "SNL"?
-It was amazing.
Actually, just as I was
coming out here, it reminded me
of being in that little --
when you walk out
onto "Saturday Night Live,"
you kind of stand
in a little coffin.
-It's tiny.
-And then the door opens,
and there's the incredible band.
And, you know, as a child,
you watch those things,
and then, suddenly,
you find yourself
a working actor
and being invited to host
"Saturday Night Live."
And now, all of a sudden,
you're walking into something
that you've seen
hundreds of times,
and it's you walking out
into that environment.
And it's --
it's -- it's bizarre.
But just before they opened
the door and I went out,
Lorne Michaels
stuck his head in, and he said,
"Hey, kid, have a good time,"
and he shut the door.
And I thought,
"Yeah, that's what you do.
Go out and have a good time."
[ Laughter ]
-I want to ask about
"Stranger Things."
You know, the first season,
when you were in it,
I feel like not many TV shows
have had premiere seasons
like this.
And it must have introduced you
to a much younger generation
doing a show
like "Stranger Things."
Did people approach you
more once you were in it?
-When the show broke,
I was doing a television --
I don't know what --
like, a miniseries in Italy.
And all the little Italian
children were coming up
and saying, "Papa, Papa, Papa!"
[ Laughter ]
And I thought,
"That's really weird.
Why are they calling me Papa?"
And my children call me Papa.
So...
And then,
two plus two equaled four,
and I realized that it was
because of the show.
And then -- you know, let's say
"Full Metal Jacket"
is the most successful film
of my career,
which just had
its 30th anniversary.
-An incredible film
that endures.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
And at that time, there's 164
territories in the world.
Netflix is in 162 territories.
They're not, I think,
in North Korea and China.
And so to have a success today
in that kind of regard
is beyond anything
that you could ever imagine.
It's really weird and bizarre.
And kudos to all the young kids
on the show
for keeping their feet
on the ground.
-Yeah.
-I mean, we've grown up
seeing what this industry
can do to children,
how it chews them up
and digests them.
And Millie Bobby Brown,
who I have most of my work with
on the show --
all of my work with --
is just the loveliest,
you know, kindest,
grounded person that you ever
met, and I love her.
-It's one of the nice, like,
sort of side stories about
the "Stranger Things" phenomenon
is watching all those kids
grow up and realize
that they're all good people.
-Yeah, she was 11 years old
when we met.
-It's crazy.
Do you -- you --
Now, obviously,
this was a big twist
that your character came back.
I think a lot of people assumed
Dr. Brenner was dead.
-Was dead.
-Did you know from the beginning
that you would come back
for this season?
-Well, the Duffers
always promised
that I was gonna come back.
They didn't know how,
and they kept structuring
the show like, "He's gonna come
back in a big way in season 2."
And then I came just as a memory
or a phenomenon of a chimera.
And then season 3,
they just said,
"We're gonna save you
for season 4." And so...
-Did you believe them,
or did you start doubting it?
-I started doubting it.
[ Laughter ]
-Once you knew --
I mean, obviously,
this is one of those shows
where, you know, spoilers,
obviously, are forbidden.
The audience
doesn't want them, either.
Did you have to keep the secret?
Was it a tough secret
for you to keep?
-It was.
You know, the other thing
that didn't have -- exist a few
years ago was social media.
By the way, there's an emo --
emo-ji? Emoji?
-Yeah, emo-ji.
-Emo-ji.
An emo-ji.
-"Papa, Papa, emo-ji!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-When I'm texting to people,
I often use one.
And when I text, I'm gonna use
the Seth Meyers emoji.
-Emoji, yeah.
What's the Seth Meyers emoji?
[ Laughter ]
Wait.
You think the shrug emoji?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I don't think that's right.
I don't think
that's very fair at all.
[ Laughter ]
-I think -- there it is.
-All right, there it is.
I don't know.
Does that --
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We just need to change
the color of his hair.
-Yeah, exactly.
So, hey, you know,
we've mentioned your work with
Kubrick on "Full Metal Jacket."
And, you know, obviously,
you're in your 20s.
Stanley Kubrick
is already Stanley Kubrick
when he's making that film.
What was it like to meet him
for the first time?
And I would imagine
just auditioning for him,
in general,
must have been terrifying.
-Well, I didn't audition.
He sent me --
I was at a diner in Los Angeles,
a very famous restaurant
called The Source,
and it was made famous
because Woody Allen,
when he went out
to find Annie Hall,
Diane Keaton, in "Annie Hall,"
he didn't know how --
He was a New Yorker
and didn't know how
to drive that big Cadillac.
And he thinks
he's put the car in reverse
and drives into the restaurant.
So I was sitting with somebody
I know you know,
David Alan Grier...
-Yeah.
-...wonderful comedic actor
and dramatic actor.
And we had just won this prize
at the Venice Film Festival
for Best Actor,
and we were hoping
that Woody Allen was in New York
and not in Los Angeles
driving around
looking for Annie Hall,
because in movies,
it's funny when somebody
drives a car into a restaurant.
In real life,
people get crushed and killed.
-Yeah.
-So we were eating our pancakes,
and there was a guy
sitting over there.
And I didn't know who it was.
It was Val Kilmer.
And he was looking at me,
saying obscene things to me.
And I said, "David,
unless that's an actor
learning his lines
or somebody with Tourette's,
he's clearly telling me
to go 'F' myself."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And he looked
over his shoulder.
He says, "Oh, it's Val Kilmer.
He's a really nice guy,"
and he invited me over.
I said, "Hi.
My name's Matthew."
"I know who you are.
I'm sick of you, man."
And I said, like, "What's up?"
And I had been on a run.
You know, actors,
every once in a while,
we get on a really good run,
and I'd done a bunch of movies.
And he said,
"Now you're doing
Kubrick's movie,
'Full Metal Jacket.'"
I said, "You don't
have to worry about that.
I'm not doing
'Full Metal Jacket.'
If you have a problem
with the rest of my career,
why don't we go outside
and settle it?"
'Cause I'm the youngest
of seven kids.
I've been fighting
my whole life.
[ Laughter ]
And David stopped it.
And I ran out,
and I called my agent.
And I said,
"This actor, Val Kilmer,
just said
I'm doing Kubrick's movie,"
and he said, "I don't know
anything about it."
I said, "I don't, either."
But I know he makes his movies
with Warner Bros.,
and I'd just done
"Vision Quest."
And Alan Parker was editing
"Birdy" in London.
I said, "Let's just
send him some clips."
And we did,
and then a month later,
I got the script in the mail --
"Hi. My name is Stanley Kubrick.
I'm a film director."
[ Laughter ]
"And I wonder if you'd be
interested in being in my film."
-Unbelievable!
-Yeah.
-Val Kilmer called it!
-Val Kilmer called it.
So I have to say,
"Tank you, Val Kilmer"!
-Thank you, Val Kilmer.
-For everything!
-For everything.
-That's a great story.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Next time, whether I'm talking
to myself or not, say hello.
Matthew Modine, everybody!
Volume 2 of season 4
of Netflix's "Stranger Things"
begins streaming July 1st.
We'll be right back
with music from Billy Strings!